you know the way i see it is the higher
levels of unhappiness and you know
honestly you could probably pull the
scientific studies and figure out you
know what the cause of that is
i i think freedom contributes to
happiness
i think rights contribute to happiness
but then i think
social stress and anxiety contribute
more so
to unhappiness so i don't i don't know
if it's if i wonder if you could
look at social pressures and social
media
and find that it affects men and women
fairly equally in different ways
like you you look at young women in
instagram and you have these instagram
models that are all touched up with
photoshop and everything
and it's resulting in anxiety stress and
depression it's social issues that are
causing it
maybe you could argue that if you took
away someone's freedom and they didn't
have access to these
platforms then they wouldn't be unhappy
with them but i actually
i don't i don't think that makes sense i
think it's just like
you know burning down the house because
you had a you know a plumbing problem in
the kitchen
you know what i mean i think by all
means keep the house fix the plumbing
find out what the problem is i think the
problem is
with unhappiness in general be it males
or females is social media
it's creating this pressure to conform
to certain things
to say certain things and then you it
results in like we mentioned before with
people like you know keith olbermann
saying
insane things about taking vaccines away
from people in texas because you don't
like their opinions
it results in people advocating for
beating others and committing acts of
violence
because they're increasingly more and
more desperate to fit in
we talk a lot about how young women are
influenced by instagram
there there was like apparently cosmetic
surgery based on snapchat filters or
something like this because they want to
clean their yeah yeah they want
yeah really creepy stuff young women who
will will post a photo on instagram
and then not get enough likes and get
really depressed and start freaking out
it's really negatively impacting these
kids
but then how how is it affecting men
because i'm sure it absolutely does
as you were speaking i was thinking um
you know and i relate this to
relate this to myself especially
especially as a as i guess a former
actor i don't know anymore
but you know like i follow the rock for
instance and i mean i love i mean i love
the guy i'm a huge pro wrestling fan or
at least i was
back when it was good and they i think
in terms of men and again this might
this might lead into sexual dynamics and
you know and and
and where people perceive their value to
lie maybe within the sexual marketplace
maybe not but
if we're talking about uh you know women
using filters and
and beautifying themselves on these
platforms and not feeling beautiful
enough in comparison to other women
what about these other accounts with you
see these men who are you know i'm
starting a business and i have this
amount of money
exactly i got this car i got this house
i got this and that
so i think a lot of guys are looking at
that and they're being like well that's
not me
i mean i guess i'm just a big i'm just a
freaking loser man i don't know
i don't got nothing and then you know
and i got these all these women are
commenting
on on on on these posts and so maybe you
know that's part of it
maybe that's contributing to uh to male
um unhappiness as well the the success
uh status that the status comparison is
what i'm getting guys not having
not having kids guys not having
relationships staying home and playing
video games all day
you know not not advancing i think i i
look i don't want to
just kind of shift this and dump it all
into social media but i really do think
social media is a huge issue
is affecting both men and women it's
really the education around it too like
you said it's not
the freedom that's destroying them it's
their misuse of it because like you have
the freedom to light your body on fire
but you know
not to and if you knew that the it
wasn't the filters that made you
beautiful
that would help some people you know
look you got a freedom not to eat a
whole ice cream cake from baskin robbins
but some people
will do it you know what i mean and i
was also thinking like when i would post
uh a video on something of me being like
oh i feel like crap
you two tweets two retweets two likes
and then less people would want to
follow me i post a picture of me on a
boat with a bunch of beautiful women
everybody wants to be my friend take a
look at this what you were saying about
these guys
casey neistat you familiar with casey oh
yeah he's like one of the he's like the
godfather of vlogging on youtube
look at his look at his biggest videos
with 50 million views what is it
i'm in a luxury first class 20 000
airplane ticket
you know mini hotel in a plane it's it's
a lot of his biggest stuff was
flaunting extreme wealth and status and
i'm not i'm not saying it disparaging
disparage him in any way i'm not saying
it on purpose i'm saying
you know he did a a video vlog where he
was flying on a
on a emirates flight it's like a 20 000
ticket
and they give you a room and apparently
there's like a shower in it or something
like it's really crazy
wow i don't know if that was his video
but his video was like he has this
little little room he's in
and it gets like 50 million views
because people want to see that status
it's like
it's why we had shows like lifestyle the
rich and famous and cribs
so very much so as we've entered the
space where
you now control your own media outlet
everybody's a public figure
for some reason and by all means the
feminists can tell me
why this is happening women have started
to focus specifically around
beautification
getting likes for their appearance and
their bodies
maybe it's a maybe it's a bad thing and
they shouldn't do it by all means
feminists can tell me
you know comment below and say they
shouldn't i'm not asserting my opinion
i'm just saying it's happening
well there's also you know it's the
question of power and you know and again
i go back to
you know my job and it's kind of funny
there's a comedian named patrice o'neill
who unfortunately passed away many years
ago from complications of diabetes but
you know he talks about how
he said he said i wish i could just walk
around for one day as a beautiful woman
because he talks about how you know they
they could be
the the plainest person just to have
nothing going on for them but if they
look good they can walk
they can walk around as if they're
celebrities and so i so i look at and so
again i'm at this i'm at this job and i
see it every day there is so much
and and it's strange i mean the same
thing i i try to watch my words because
i know that i will also get heat from
from gender activists and feminists
but to deny the power the raw power of a
of a beautiful woman
and the effect that it has on a man i
mean and even other women say like oh
she's so pretty
you know what do you do it's there is
something about that i don't even know
if i can put it into words or articulate
it but
it definitely has an effect you can be
you know i mean
i don't consider myself somebody who um
i guess but by the nature of my
profession i'm used to being around
beautiful women so it's it's demystified
for me and and
in a way it's made me even more choosy
as far as who i choose to to date
because i'm like okay well i see all of
that but
you know what's what's inside what's
going on up here what's going on in here
but i i just even even i am sometimes
just like
so hey
powerful it's just feminine wild
and honestly it doesn't even have to be
she doesn't even have to be super duper
attractive she could just have a certain
way about her that's
what we kind of say you know and it can
it can completely disarm you and you
just you don't
you don't know what i mean anthony and
cleopatra um
uh uh the shakespeare play that's that's
sort of what it's about you see
this powerful man this general this
warrior and cleopatra is at home and she
has him wrapped around her finger
it's amazing do you have any like male
heroes or people you look up to like
you're a big fan of
um i have i have i have a few
do you ever meet them well a lot of them
are dead
but but one right right now that uh
that i like a lot is is actually malcolm
x and which is which i think might
surprise a lot of people given my
viewpoints i mean
i'm sure people who follow him would
call me and uncle tom and all those
other things but the thing about it
in his autobiography in the epilogue or
the afterward to it uh the
the actor aussie davis who's no longer
with us unfortunately
he made the point that malcolm taught us
how to be a man when we were not allowed
to be men
and there's this clip that he of this um
this press conference that he gave after
his journey to mecca
and he um he was asked about
bringing the the case of of racial
discrimination and oppression of
of of black americans to the united
nations
and he he said malcolm said i'm gonna
paraphrase but he said you know i i i
would not be a man if i did not
you know pursue this action and bri and
he repeated it because i just if i
didn't bring this case against the
uh up to the u.n i would not be a man
and so for me
um you know even though the concept of
of maleness is is consistently derided
now
um i think there is a
true power in in being able to say this
is what i'm standing for this is what i
believe in
and i'm willing to put my life on the
line to say this and
you know it's one of the things that
that inspires me to keep on running my
mouth right now is like you know if i
don't say something about this
then i would not be a man whatever that
means or a human
or or well but so well before before we
go too far okay yeah yeah
the reason i asked is you know you're
talking about how you meet this woman
and you get tongue-tied
and i started thinking about this a
while ago you know when they talk about
what
the average male or female finds
attractive it's like guys want
young beautiful women and there's a
variety of physical features that men
are attracted to
the okay cupid cupid data showed that
it's like 22 year old women almost
exclusively like
no matter how old the guy gets he always
goes for 22 year olds
and then i thought okay well well they
say like what do they say about what
makes women
you know attracted to a man confidence
charisma and status
and i'm like so is there so you
mentioned that like a woman could have a
woman could have nothing going on for
her but just be beautiful
and then guys are like fawning all over
and all over yeah and i was like
so then what's the male equivalent of
this high
societal value and its status notoriety
and fame
and i'm like so then i wonder if there
are similarities between
you know guys who look at women and
they're like woo and guys who look at a
celebrity or a famous individual and
yell at them
not sexual advances obviously which
definitely gives guys a bit of that
privilege
because you know i'm sure a lot of it's
disgusting but when you're a guy walking
on the street and you have
people like hollering at you and yelling
at you like yo yo can i get a picture of
a big fan
it's not identical but there's a
similarity there in this is what society
values in men this is what society
values in women
interestingly enough though women will
still get it worse when they're famous
and beautiful
because now everybody's yelling at you
because you're famous and they're
yelling at you because you're beautiful
so it's an interesting dynamic and the
reason i asked about male heroes is i
was wondering
do you think you would get tongue-tied
if you came across a male
you know hero of yours who you looked up
to and was inspired by so probably so
yeah i want that's not just just an idea
i was wondering about you there's a
actually in the film malcolm x denzel
washington he was so unbelievable in
this role like
to this day when i see a picture of the
real malcolm i still i see both men
and there's a scene where in the film
where malcolm meets
elijah muhammad and denzel plays it so
beautifully
he he has he has his head down and you
see tears start streaming down his face
this is a man who spent
his time in prison educating himself
learning how to speak this dude was a
former pimp
you know he goes into detail in his
autobiography yeah about how he learned
that the street slang you know
you know and so he so he he knows how to
talk to people
and yet in this at least as depicted in
this movie
he meets you know his his idol and he
he can't say anything he just starts he
just starts crying it's it's
such a powerful beautiful moment and you
know and i
i will say i did get to meet harry
belafonte
and um that that is somebody that i said
you know i
i wonder if what i would say to him if i
ever met him
and um i did a show off broadway where
he played the it was a
play called carmen jones and he did the
movie adaptation of it and he played a
character named joe which is what i
played off broadway and one night he
came to the show
and i i've been saying to myself what
would i say to him
if he showed up and i'm somebody who
is who is extraordinarily grateful to
the people that came before me which is
another reason why i step off i step
away from this woke stuff because i feel
like they keep erasing the heroes of the
past
but you know i got out i got out of the
theater walked around the corner and
there he is this 91 year old man
in this wheelchair eyes still bright
these bright blue eyes these great
cheekbones
and at a certain point you know i just
said thank you thank you for everything
that you have done
you're you're a warrior and you're a
trailblazer and
you know i just i just want to shake
your hand and you know like can i get a
hug and he just he got up
he's old 91 year old rickety self made i
get emotional thinking about it and you
know there's video of it and we just
and we hugged each other you know and so
that so that's one instance where you
know as
i said i just was like that i met a a a
trailblazer and the hero where i was
like you know thank you so maybe
so maybe it's maybe say what not talking
not tongue type but but
i guess what i'm getting at is that
maybe it's it depends on who the guy is
and what situation that he's in his life
like i see other guys at the gym or
whatever and
you know they look good they're ripped
or whatever and i'm like wow good for
that guy
you know that guy looks amazing or i'll
see somebody who's like doing their
thing they're running a business they
make my name like
wow good for that guy like you know i
could you know be there somewhere but at
the same time the flip side might be
man you just may okay it's we're keeping
the family friendly so i can't uh i
can't say what i want to say but man
look at this dude you flashing all this
man you got these big muscle man
whatever you just you know
we call them haters yeah yeah yeah to be
uh i got a lot of them on twitter oh
oh i bet you do my friend you know i i
remember i was working
uh i worked at work in california once
when i was doing fundraising and i saw a
dude pull up in a very expensive car
you know like convertible and i'm just
thinking like
he looked really young like early 20s
and i'm like what is he doing
like what is he doing and i was like
amen he's like yo what up i'm like
what are you doing like you're making
all this money you clearly look like
you're doing well
it's a real estate and so it's like i
saw that and i went to a guy and i was
like yo yo
i want to talk to you real quick because
i saw his power and his status you know
what i mean and i was like give me some
advice
like he was a little bit older than me
and i was like
what is this how do you afford this what
do you do for a living what's the what's
the key how did you get started
tell me tell me those secrets you know
what i mean that's like that that's the
plot of uh
of the pursuit of happiness remember
that uh that will smith movie
where he was making a true story wasn't
it yeah yeah but he sees a guy and
driving a nice car and he's like you
know what do you do well i'm a stock
broker he's like well
i want to learn how to do that how do i
learn how to you know so i mean that's
that's the kind of thing you know i i
just i was speaking about this this
earlier uh to one of your colleagues
just about
this this creeping nihilism this lack of
this lack of aspiration
you know there's no
people
it's as if uh and especially with the
response to to covet people just content
with sitting in and just shutting
themselves in all day and
and never striving for anything and in
wanting to strive for something that
makes you greedy it makes you selfish
you're not you're only thinking of
yourself but you know
how if you're constantly denigrating
people who want to build something or to
achieve something yeah they might maybe
they are selfish
but if that drives them to create you
know if that drives an elon musk to you
know to
launch rockets into space you know what
i mean then what's what's what's the
deal what's the problem with that why
can't we aspire to be like these people
um instead of tearing them down it seems
like there's a huge
huge cultural movement where it's like
any striving for any kind of achievement
or whatever is is
is looked down upon crabs in a barrel
man crabs and
like like resentment like if you're not
if someone's not striving and then they
see someone that is there might be this
resentment maybe it's the reason do you
know the fries crabs in a barrel grabs
in a bucket
they snap at each other because they all
went out at the same time so when one is
climbing out the other one grabs trying
to pull itself up they only knew if they
worked together they could all get out
the bottom guy would climb up their
backs first pull them off one at a time
the guy at the top would have to hang
there and carry the weight of all the
other crabs
some we need one of those crabs to like
introduce crab communism so they
understand the power of the collective
you know yes get a bunch of crabs to
cling onto the barrel in a circle and
then a bunch of crabs
so you have like a funnel of crabs and
that way yeah distribute the weight
together decentralize
it's the age-old mathematical problem
we've now solved it the crabs in a
barrel mathematical equation
simple there it is and all the crabs
that disagree kill them
and then we eat them there we got some
butter perfect everyone wins in this
scenario
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you